I get my best performance when there's
like a meaningful object like in the set
or like in the scene did you use that
for the film no because I we were alone
we were alone in a recording booth
[Music]
I took for my parents a little bit
because they're theater kids they met in
theater and then they created a theater
kid that got to play a theater kid so
Margo is really big and expressive and
loud and every moment is the moment
Curtain Call at all times she is on on
stage at all times she's you know
producing directing her friends at all
times she's just a nut oh life is not a
dress rehearsal it's time for you to go
big and go to bro so I spent a lot of my
summer
at my parents Cottage and there's a big
rock by the lake and I would spend like
a lot of time lounging on the Rock
willing myself to become a mermaid just
being like come on
I'm a mother flipping Mermaid so I did
that for a while so I feel like I feel
like I feel like like I had to draw
something from that Ruby gets like
overwhelmed very quickly she spirals
very easily that's something as a
performer fun to play it's so tough
because the physicality when you're in a
recording booth there you don't have a
lot of freedom there because you you
don't want to move too much because you
don't want to like have the fabric pick
up on any of the mics and you don't want
to you know move away from the mics but
to me I found that if I was able to do
like like even just like wrap my limbs
like together or like hold myself a
little it helped my performance I knew
that they were gonna try and animate her
in this kind of in that capacity oh I
hope my performance was better because
of it Ruby Gilman teenage Kraken
laughs
[Music]